[Music]
Nik and I we actually met him it meant
all because they were there for paradise
promo and stuff at that men tell all
so we met briefly then and then and then
of course he's here this week and it was
a prisoner at Jingle Ball so getting out
with him for a little bit and then we
hung out actually this weekend crystals
and and [ __ ] and kind of just caught up
on on life a little bit was that the
first time that you've seen him since
the whole thing I mean what did he say
yeah it is he didn't really go there it
was a little bit of elephant room I mean
it really was and so I mean I I think
it's it's kind of water under the bridge
at this point you know and I wish the
best for my don't know how his season
went I've heard a few rumors from
different people that were involved and
then things and what rumors of your
heart Luke I wish I could say I wish I
could save it you you would be getting
me in trouble if the rumors have been
out there there have been reports that
women thought Nick was a diva there have
been reports of lots of drama I mean how
do you react to those reports um I'm
just I just take it all in and just wait
it's like a couple more weeks and it's
gonna be on Spain and we'll see but yeah
I think probably right out of the box
night one it's gonna be a little bit
different than it's been in the past so
we'll see